talking about black women disgracing
themselves but he's with an only fan's
model not that i'm shaming only fans
models because it sounds like you are
though
no i i'm pro-sex work no matter how you
put it however we know that society
views
women who do sex work as hang on your
pro sex work
pro sex work so you think sex work is
cool
i i support women who do it i didn't say
it was cool i didn't say that i would do
it i didn't say other people should do
it i said that i support it you because
at the end people giving away their
vagina for money
um
she is just posting her coochie and
making money off of it
right she's selling the coochie that's
on her it's not my coochie
no i know that but
you said your pro sex work yes meaning
i'm going to always support somebody who
is in that industry as well at the end
of the day that's the way that they want
to make money okay so as my friend if i
did sex work you'd support it
yes if you feel like that that is
absolutely necessary for real it's not
done talking okay
if i feel like it's if you feel like
it's absolutely necessary and you have
no other out and it's against your
morals i would want to talk you out of
it if anything if it's fully against
your morals and maybe your family would
be against it but if you feel fully
comfortable with doing it of course i'm
going to support you but i'm going to
tell you to be very careful that's for
sure
interesting
this is interesting um i i don't think i
would support someone that didn't
sexually no i would tell them not to do
it but i mean i guess i i think your
point is like if you're gonna do it like
i can't stop you but that's exactly it
who the hell am i to tell somebody what
to do
these people are my kids
what do i look like
what do i look like being their mom
you gotta pull the mic yeah the well
stated is is that um obviously you can't
stop anyone doing anything but i'm not
going to encourage you doing it
yeah you go for it yeah you do that yeah
if they're all right sell your vagina
i'm not going to be an advocate
yeah
i explained myself
if you feel like i didn't already
explain myself clearly that's your own
personal problem
if you want to do what you want to do
then you go ahead and do it at the end
of the day it doesn't matter what the
hell i say if you feel in your heart
that you want to do it you go and do it
regardless
what i say does not matter
but if you feel like you need somebody
at the end of the day that's going to
support you because nobody's there for
you i'm going to be a good friend to you
at the very least and be like listen bro
if you really feel like this is for you
i can't stop you
obviously your family couldn't stop you
why would i be able to stop you
it's your body
autonomy
there's a difference in that and saying
that you're pros yeah exactly so
you know what i'm saying like that's a
statement like
pro means support does it not in this
case no no
stands for progressive yes
keep going keep digging deeper
uh progressive as in
the forward movement yeah so you're
you're forwarding this so you're for
this that you're for the forward
movement of sex work i'm not anti
right because i allow other people to do
what they want right that is support i
think we are getting our terminology
mixed up yeah yeah it sounds like you
guys are getting your turns out oh no
we kind of know what we're talking about
so you kind of know we're talking about
do you guys yeah
that
does drugs and stuff like that i mean i
can't stop him but you know i'm pro
drugs yeah exactly because i'm your
friend i'm gonna say this is bad for you
bro you've got a family drugs can
literally quite literally kill you like
soaking sex with you yes unless you are
careful enough it is not so good but you
can do the same thing with drugs like
like unless your
yeah you know still survive that's fine
but the fact that y'all want to
compare it to drugs is like a whole
different ball no it's just it's the
same it's the same i almost think sex
work is worse
because because you could do like you
could do drugs get sober no one would
ever know but you put [ __ ] on the
internet that's there forever
and whose business is that but their own
yeah all the people that see it on the
internet but that's my point that's
their life i can't do much about it at
the end of the day these people are just
my friends that much is true though
that's the reason why i would not
encourage my friend doing it saying
there's going to be long-term
consequences if you do this but don't
you think that they would have thought
that through several times already
before getting into it not necessarily
because they're in a
uh how can i put a heightened state
whereby they they're work they're
working emotionally or not logically how
many people do you know when sex work
i don't surround myself okay the
positive enough how many people do you
know okay
them it's not a fight there's no fight
there's no fight
it's just it's just a
friendly conversation yeah but i don't
surround myself with it oh okay
should we take the gloves off now
okay the glove's been off
like i don't surround myself with the
president doesn't mean does it mean i
cannot have an opinion on the president
who the hell no i'm just saying because
the president is one person right and so
are
but you were just saying that if you
don't surround yourself with sex workers
you can't really have an opinion
yeah that too i agree
i agree